let's uh let's just quickly go into the
more serious nature of what's happening
because we have uh here's here's a story
uh
this is uh one of the most recent
stories we've been able to find abc 7
reporting at 7 pm 13 u.s service members
killed in kabul airport attacks
biden says attackers will pay we will
not forgive we will not forget we will
hunt you down and make you pay biden
said
two suicide bombers and gunmen attacked
crowds of afghans flocking to kabul's
airport thursday transforming a scene of
desperation into one of horror in the
waning days of an airlift for those
fleeing the taliban takeover the attacks
killed at least 60 afghans and 13 u.s
troops
afghan and u.s officials i think one of
the most harming things
i heard was a
a man who was an interpreter for the
marine corps
called into fox news and said that after
the blast there was a you know
five-year-old little girl that he was
trying to resuscitate and she died in
his arms
this didn't have to happen
why why are we in this mess no this had
to happen i
there's so much of the criticism that
has been directed at the bite
administration which by the way they've
tried to deflect by conflating criticism
for how we are withdrawing
with the
cr very sort of non-existent criticism
that we should have never left the main
argument isn't we shouldn't leave
afghanistan i think most people actually
do support that a lot of polling shows
that especially recent polling the
criticism is for how we have done it
in the weeks since this has happened it
has been clear that everything they have
done has been made up as they go there
was no plan they claimed they planned
for all contingencies clearly they did
not they evacuated the military before
they evacuated our allies and civilians
in the dead of night no
and they didn't they didn't inform the
field commander at bagram base by the
way they didn't tell the afghani
commander they just irish goodbye
overnight
after 20 years it's like a bad boyfriend
um
so one thing that i i hear repeatedly
when i criticize or i talk about this on
social media or write about it are these
kind of you know the twitter biden
stands responding oh could you could you
be doing it better yes yes i could
number one don't
you you evacuate your civilians first
leave your military there as a rear
guard then you take out your combat
troops this is so don't close down
bagram it has two airstrips it's also
secluded and and strategically situated
instead they've bottlenecked everyone
in an international airport in kabul
that's surrounded by the taliban and
we're now completely dependent on
whether or not the taliban will pretty
please let our people live it's how many
people in kabul 5 million or or
something like that roughly i'd have to
double check but so it's a very dense
urban populated area and now we're
asking our soldiers and marines and
everyone else over there to essentially
ferry these people to safety despite the
fact they're completely surrounded this
needs to be stressed to all of the
people who are desperate to say it's not
biden's fault
first thing i'll give you is when they
say it's george w bush fault i go all
right well to a certain jury i would
agree with that but
donald trump had a peace deal and a plan
for for for the evacuation for the pull
out and
yeah i don't think joe biden had a plan
no that's the thing too is like look we
can say trump's plan was garbage we can
say was ill-advised we could say we're
stupid that doesn't matter biden is not
beholden to it he's a grown-ass
president he can make his own decisions
and he has shown repeatedly he has no
problem overturning trump executive
actions trump policies or anything else
related to trump he ran on the fact that
he would overturn everything so the idea
that because he's been striking this
bizarre uh tone where it's paradoxical
where he says no yeah i made the
decision because i care about america
also my hands are tied what can i do but
this is this already we have we got to
break this down and make sure everybody
understands this the original deadline
was may 1st you should not in the middle
of the night skip out on your strategic
air force base which is i believe about
45 miles outside of kabul
that it's got what two runways two
runways yeah so
i mean the first thing i started reading
when i'm reading from the opinions of
national security experts military
experts in these in these in these
various op-eds
why did they in the middle of the night
abandon
the the base along with our resources
our weapons just the blackhawk
helicopters
and then say okay
now now for everybody who's still there
if you want to leave go to the airport
why
i'm just i'm confused i'm genuinely
confused because let me just stress this
point
either they're really really dumb or
they did it on purpose this is something
we keep coming back to where you you
know the old saying is never attribute
malice uh to that which can be uh
explained simply by stupid razor thank
you my favorite but you're looking at
this is how we left military aircraft
which now the taliban have and they are
almost certainly going to sell that to
the chinese or russians to disseminate
and study and make their own versions we
left hundreds of guns we left millions
of dollars we left trucks
and then again taking military out first
doesn't make any sense you look at this
and you go why and how i keep getting
stuck on that and the sort of
the nonsensical approach that biden has
taken to this every step of the way is
we had to get out
and then when the taliban came and
overran the country nobody saw this was
would happen then the bombs go off today
and essentially it's well you know this
is why we have to leave and also
we have to leave and also send in more
troops because we now need to go get the
people who did this what is there a plan
where where where is the political
commentary going from what a couple days
ago it was this is literally trump's
plan it's trump's fault now they're
saying bombs go off all the time in
afghanistan that's why we're leaving
but so it goes to the point we're like
who cares if this is trump's thing you
are president now today he was asked at
his press conference uh president biden
was as if he takes full responsibility
for the dead marines and the navy medic
the corpsman and he answered i'm not
even loosely paraphrasing i take full
responsibility but remember this was
trump's plan that's what he said he did
say that he was responding to peter
ducey at fox news trump's plan was not
to leave in august right that was may
1st that's the other thing to point out
is that he keeps saying i am tied to
what trump did they already blew through
the deadline established by the trump
administration and the point we keep
coming back to is trump's plan didn't
involve shuttering bagram getting the
military out first and then abandoning
u.s nationals and our allies that was
never in the trump plan
i don't i i i it's hard for me to
believe that this dumb to be complete
because
you know that if you pull the military
out before your the civilians and you
abandon an air force base you know this
is going to happen
so i mean look we keep coming back is it
stupidity because they say we didn't
have any intelligence general miley said
we didn't have anything indicating that
the taliban would essentially retake the
entire country within seven days the
intelligence community is saying
otherwise somebody is this like the the
line from the old dire straits song is
that two men say they're jesus one of
them's got to be wrong that's what this
feels like okay somebody's not telling
the truth right now they've got to be
hearing something i mean they got they
knew of course they knew they were ready
to take the country in seven days they
they'd known that
we were evacuating for like eight months
they've been ready for this moment no
but we weren't supposed to pull
logistics and support for for the
afghans yeah they smelled blood and they
seized the opportunity well there were
videos going back uh a month or two ago
where the afghan commandos were fighting
back and then when they there's this
video it's horrifying they run out of
ammo so they surrender
and the taliban comes in and executes
them all films it all puts it on the
internet
so they they didn't immediately just say
we give up no the biden administration
abandoned them as you mentioned didn't
even tell the the was it the commander
the afghan yeah he was the commander he
was the airfield uh commander there just
yeah at bagram he was the bagram
commander of the afghan army i'm looking
at a satellite image of bagram and kabul
how who in their right mind would think
that that
evacuating bagram would make any sense
if you look at people yeah they're like
in a valley together kabul and bagram
surrounded by mountains like defensible
location why would they why would they
abandon that airstrike the only way you
can get to that airstrip is with trucks
or with a
uh what's the word i'm looking for with
an air force neither of which well
taliban have trucks but they well they
have an air force no they do because we
abandoned bagram uh this is the thing
biden also claimed today that he was
advised by his top commanders and
military advisors that bagram could be
left because it didn't provide much of a
strategic output so like again i don't
want to jump on the impeach train or
whatever too soon but at this point
there need to be hearings especially now
that american blood has been shed which
i just want to clarify one of the more
really irritating and insidious
narratives that has been kind of
bubbling up in the press right now is
well you know not a lot of americans
have died yeah what about our afghan
allies who are being hunted they're
being executed they're being and their
homes are being you know door-to-door
they're being dragged out in the street
they're being tortured that doesn't
matter just as long as american blood's
not [ __ ] and now and now they're saying
well you know the bombs go off it
happens all the time and of course
that's why we're getting out in the
first place it's not biden's fault no
i'll tell you what i said um what many
people said what almost every single
person we've had on this show has said
it is so such common sense
abandoning american citizens
in in kabul
abandoning bagram air force base
you better prepare yourself for what's
to come the next several days when we
start seeing the blood of americans and
our allies now
what we're seeing here
man it's like it's got getting punched
in the gut because we knew it was bad
already
and we are i kind of feel like in the
past few days i was thinking like wow
biden screwed this one up but hearing
that they were securing the the the
airport and they were getting out i was
like okay he botched this americans are
going to be stranded
but maybe this ends at the very least
without reaching this level like i
didn't i didn't part of me i guess
wanted to hold out thinking like we're
not going to see you know bombs going
off at the airport i i'm i mean i guess
i'll just disagree i thought the moment
that they bottlenecked themselves in
kabul it's surrounded by the taliban
we're completely at the mercy i'm what
i'm saying emotionally
i was i was sitting here thinking like
it's going to be okay
like the americans are in trouble that i
get our allies they're in there but i
have a feeling like there's a chance
that we're gonna we're gonna at least
just taper off here it's not going to
escalate to that point and it was i
think it was me being i was just
naively hopeful well but also like i was
saying before the show too the taliban i
think the taliban wants to be recognized
legitimately as the government of
afghanistan so they're willing to play
ball here and make sure these people get
out safely but there's lots of rogue
elements with explosives that are that
want to kill well isis k has claimed
responsibility for the bombing today
which apparently isis k is the off
branch of the old isis but to your point
i i think a lot of us are gonna have to
prepare ourselves emotionally mentally
spiritually whatever
uh for if there are americans left
behind which i guess
i should add right now the white house
is very clearly signaling that they they
themselves believe americans will be
left behind they will be captured and we
will see happen to them most likely what
isis has done to their prisoners they
line them up in their orange suits and
they make propaganda out of them thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you